hey what is
up this is the dr john deloney show i'm
john
i'm so happy to be here i hope you're
doing well
i hope you have survived christmas
whether
it was wonderful and exciting and you
got to be with kids who
got to open presents whether you had to
get up and go to work
and serve the least of these whether
you're a nurse
and your shift doesn't stop no matter
what day it is
whether you are picking up the trash in
the neighborhood and you got your
headphones in right now
i hope you survived if you had to go to
your family's house and it was a
disaster
i hope you are back on track you're
doing okay you're recovering whatever it
may be you may be listening to this in a
closet
in your cousin's
bathroom i don't even know who's got
closets in the bathroom it may be you
and so if it is awesome we're gonna do
something a little different today
so i put out on the interwebs on the
social medias the other day
an ama ask me anything i've been getting
a lot of requests
whether it's direct messages or emails
or facebook
connections is how you say that facebook
connections i sound like a 111 years old
just then
yes facebook messages yes said james
otherwise known as
the deity of my choice right um
asking me certain questions about why do
i do what i do how do i do it
what are things that i believe in what
are the things that i actually do with
my life and so i thought i would compile
all that
do an ama and ask me anything and just
go through some of these questions
if you don't want to hear that if you
tune in every every time a show drops to
hear what's going on in somebody else's
life
if you hear tune in to just hear like
whoa
i thought my life was bad i'm glad it's
not that or i'm experiencing the exact
same thing
then this won't be the show for you you
can just check out if you want to have
some fun
and dig into some of the things behind
the thing
some of the reasons i say what i say and
where those things come from this is
gonna be a fun show
so we're gonna jump in and do and ask me
anything we've got kelly and james here
they can actually speak into the show
today which is going to be fun
and if i just blow by something or say
something stupid they are
going to feel free to make fun of me and
pop in like they always do
can i do that from now on on every show
every show you are welcome you do do
that
here's the thing folks james can speak
into my ear where only i can hear him
and he can speak into
everybody's ears everybody can hear him
so y'all don't know how much he tortures
me
i look directly at kelly and she
sometimes makes faces that are worse
than my wife and my
mom combined yeah but this is the first
time that i can actually speak on the
air
i know it hurts man it hurts and it
makes me nervous and uncomfortable
all right so let's go in question number
one that came up a lot
is what is my morning routine i talk a
lot about having routine controlling
what you can control what are the things
that you can do every day
and it started with ben greenfield a
decade ago
benggreenfieldfitness.com is a guy that
i trust a guy that i have high respect
for
and who practices what he preaches also
a few years ago tim ferriss
of the four hour work week fame came out
with a book called tools of titans it's
about two or three inches thick and it
just has morning routines and daily
practices
of everyone from i don't know
professional bowlers to
neuroscientists to astronauts and
everybody in between
and so consensus is that people who
achieve
things that help them be well and i
don't want to say success because i
think a mom of three kids who's making
it work is
highly successful and i think someone
who can put a man on the moon is highly
successful
someone who's figuring out how to mine
an asteroid is highly successful
and somebody who works at a used car
dealership and makes sure people have
a affordable car to get to work is
successful and so
an underlying theme there is that they
have a morning routine
often that they don't budge on or if
they budge on it it is
barely so here is my routine i do it
almost
every single morning sometimes there's
little tweaks and variations here and
there
and we're going to put some of this
stuff in the show notes this will be a
packed show notes thing so if you don't
want to just take notes you can
click in and check out the show but
here's here's the way it works
i wake up somewhat early usually between
5 and 5 45
on most days i try to get seven to nine
hours of sleep
seven eight hours i really don't like to
budge on that
occasionally like once a month i'll
sleep until seven
and several times a month i wake up at 4
30 if i get up at 4 30 on my own i just
get up and go ahead and go do the day
i turn on the coffee pot i make my bed
my wife is a writer and so she's usually
up before me riding
so i make the bed boom i started off the
day with a win
turn on the coffee pot and i immediately
go to my gratitude journal
if you're watching on youtube this is my
gratitude journal the actual one and i
ride in it
i just grab a marker these i grabbed out
of my kids
but i write down five things that i'm
grateful for they start with the
sentence i'm grateful for
then i reach over and grab a bible i'm a
christian
guy and so scripture guides my life
and i will write down a scripture that's
going to be my guiding one for the day
and i put that on my little note card
my note card is what guides me i don't
have a fancy app i don't have
a plan or anything like that i've got a
note card that i carry in my pocket and
i check on it
and i mark things off as i go i then
move to
meditation whether that's five minutes
or 15 minutes
usually i use the insight timer app it's
free
and i don't make any money by the way
i'm not making any money on any of the
things i recommend here these are just
things that i do on my own
and i will meditate for 5 to 15 minutes
i also spent a year with a professor who
was a monk and so
i've done a number of my own chants and
learned a number of my own meditation
set through him and so i will do those
too
i've got my own little tibetan bell down
in my little home office
the point of meditation is to be still
learn to control my thoughts
and experiences and if you think of your
thoughts like a muscle
meditation helps you bring them back and
when they wander you bring them back
then i head upstairs and i grab some
coffee for years i drink black coffee
i'm working on something now with dr
josh axe's green
matcha colostrum it's an ancient
nutrition product
it's pretty good i like it i'm several
days into it and i like it a lot
i mix 5050 decaf to caffeinated
and i think we the science is pretty
clear that caffeine helps and
we are way over stimulated group of
people and so i've been mixing at 50 50
and me and my wife and it's helped our
anxiety it's helped our sleep it's
helped everything so
i then put my feet on bare grass just
for a few minutes this isn't something
you do for an hour
a day does not go by when i don't touch
my bare feet to bare ground
period and i don't have caffeine after
10 except
rarely and that's just one of my little
rules
i then go work out i've been collecting
gym equipment in my garage for years if
a
um you know crossfit gym is going out of
going out of business or local you know
uh
craigslist has something for sale i'll
go buy and buy two plates
or one kettlebell and i work out
anywhere from 30 to 60 minutes i built
my own squat rack using four by fours in
a youtube video
there's just not a lot of excuses for
not working out at your house
gyms can be cool there's a good
camaraderie there it's got everything
there
but most of us have everything we need
at our house or we could collect
it over a couple of months obviously
coveted man
dude gym equipment's gotten expensive
because people are stuck at home
good for them you can even run around
your yard with
rocks you can fill up five gallon
buckets with
concrete there is a number of things you
can do to come up with weights and
workout equipment at your house
but i work out from anywhere from 30-60
minutes depending on my morning
i listen to my body sometimes i've had
several late nights in a row or i have
sleep terrible several nights in a row
and sometimes i'll just take a walk
often i'll
walk every day for a week i'll walk a
mile and a half one way and a mile and a
half back
it'll be a three mile walk other times
i'll take a walk but i'll wear a
backpack and i'll put a 35
pound weight in it like a like a
makeshift rucksack
right now i'm doing jocko's push pull
squat and lift protocol
but i'll switch them up i'll do that for
four or five months and then i'll go do
something else the goal here is this
i am i'm in my 40s now i'm in my early
40s and my goal has switched from
yeah bro i want to squat and bench press
it
now my goal is this i want to be able to
roll around and wrestle with my
grandkids when i'm 90.
i want to be a formidable opponent for
my granddaughter and my grandson
on a wrestling mat when i'm 90. and so i
am
working out on getting strong getting
lean
getting um making sure i move often and
then i'm keeping my strength
up when i went on vacation like on
thanksgiving we drove a van a thousand
miles to
you know to go to a ranch like a hunting
field and then we
went to my my parents house i put some
of my kettlebells and dumbbells
in the car and it's not uncommon for me
to do a 15-20 minute workout in a
parking lot of a hotel
or off behind a tree somewhere in the
middle of a field
it's just good to keep moving i'm
probably gonna hire a mobility a
movement coach
via online and start working on some
joint mobility and some joint muscle
strength i'll let you know how that goes
but i'm looking at that in the next
couple of months
then after my workout 30 to 60 minutes i
hang upside down on my teeter
it's an inversion table it's called the
teeter
they couldn't have come up with it i
guess it's teeter-totter right that's
what all right
um just saying i hang upside down on my
teeter just sounds weird when i say it
out loud but
um i can see pretty much all this stuff
sounds weird exactly
so i hang upside down for three minutes
uh three to five minutes and then i go
outside in my cold tub i have a
metal watering trough that i got from a
tractor supply store and i leave it
outside in the winter and it ices over
this morning i actually had to break the
ice and i sit in it for three to five
minutes
he learned how to breathe still in here
and if if
i'm not in the cold shower i mean if i'm
not in the cold tub i take cold showers
cold exposure grows new new mitochondria
there's a cellular reason why there's a
scientific a biological reason
it grows new mitochondria that's the the
battery power for your cells
it makes you stronger from the inside
out and it's good psychologically but
the whole thing takes about 45 minutes
to an hour and a half depending on my
day
and sometimes if i wake up early i'll
slow play it and do a long workout
sometimes if
i'm in a rush i'll do 45 minutes
sometimes like today was a recovery day
i spent
30 to 45 minutes with my foam roller and
with my
my i don't know jackhammer massager
thing just
stretching and getting loose and doing
some squats and then calling it good
i also build in a lot of hugs and
touching and body contact
with my wife and my two kids
i had somebody come stay with me
recently was working through some
personal challenges
and they pulled me aside one day we were
walking outside and said
do you and your wife hug that much all
the time do you and your kids
hug like that every day you just put on
a show for me and i said no we do that
every day
skin to skin contact body contact eye
contact is critical it's something we've
lost and it's something that i'm highly
intentional about in my house
sometimes we do morning dancing singing
or quiet sometimes
it is silence in the house and i can now
i just look at my wife or my son i can
just know today's gonna be a quiet day
i try to eat breakfast with my kids um
when i can sometimes i'm fasting
sometimes i'm not we'll talk about that
later
um often after drinking coffee
and a good workout there's an epic
bathroom event i'm not trying to be
gratuitous i'm just telling you that's
got to build that time in too
and then when i leave the house i put in
my
human charger especially in the winter
time for vitamin d and sunlight
i jam to music have silence prepare for
my show recordings depending on
whatever's going on
sometimes i write in the morning
sometimes i'll meditate for a long time
sometimes i do weird things like
work outside and shorts and nothing else
in the freezing weather whatever it
happens to be
but that's my morning routine pretty
much do that every single day
with little to no variation occasionally
on saturdays if i'm going to
be at a hunting ranch at 4am or i'm
going on a trip or something i'll i'll
adjust it but
getting into a rhythm of life all right
so the next thing naturally is what's my
diet what do i actually eat
now before i answer this here's the
thing diet is
i could say listen i worship satan and i
would get
less drama and hate mail i worship satan
and i i don't believe in god i could say
that out loud
and i'm gonna get less mean emails than
if i
say you know i think vegans are
psychotic or i think keto people don't
know how to read science
whatever the thing i have i'm about to
say so everybody keep your dietary
things to yourself i don't care
quite honestly do what works for you
what i will tell you is i've met with
a bajillion researchers i've spent
15 years figuring this out and there's a
couple of common themes throughout
everything
and i also know that if you adhere to
your diet
more religiously than your core
convictions you're going to make
yourself insane
so here we go i have tried every diet i
used to keep
spreadsheets of my diets right for 30
days i would try to be vegan or try to
be
raw vegan or i would eat whatever it
happened to be i had my own glucose
monitor for my blood i was a nerd my
weight i tracked everything how i felt
here's a few guidelines unequivocally no
ifs ands or buts
sugar is killing us to death slowly
quickly it's destroying us from the
inside out so
if you have one enemy in your diet it's
sugar so i have
no sugar unless i'm going all in so my
rule is i don't fall off the wagon
i climb off the wagon i park it and then
i let it run over me
so if i'm gonna eat sugar i'm gonna eat
65 cookies
and eight bags of gummy candies i'm
gonna
scrounge my neighborhood for insulin and
then i'm gonna sleep for a few days
terribly
and then i'm gonna get back into it so
on the whole i
don't eat sugar very very very few
grains
almost no grains no sugar no grains i
got that from vinnie torterrich i love
that just quick saying no sugar no
grains
especially processed grains so i hardly
ever eat bread
or hamburger buns or rice or pasta never
um i do eat my wife's sourdough bread
there's a whole other reason for that
it's live
and it processes all the gluten out et
cetera et cetera
i usually go between 15 to 16 hours
between meals
a minimum of 12 so if i quit eating
dinner at 6 30 i won't eat again until 6
30 the next day
intermittent fasting is important
sometimes 20 hours sometimes
one or two day fast that's a whole other
conversation so i won't dig into that
lots and lots of fats high high quality
fats
lots of high quality meats i get my meat
from a grass-fed butcher in missouri
actually drive and go pick it up
lots of grass-fed butters i do put heavy
cream in my coffee
when i'm not fasting lots of vegetables
and i eat frozen berries with heavy
cream i get big bags of frozen berries
from costco
and i will warm them up and put
heavy cream in there i don't drink a ton
maybe a drink or two a week maybe every
two weeks
usually it'll be whiskey occasionally
beer or organic wine but
i just don't drink very much the more i
practice not drinking much the more i
realize i just feel better i don't sleep
as well
if i have a couple of drinks um i
challenge everybody take 30 days off a
drink and see how you feel you're
probably going to feel a lot better
then it goes to what supplements we'll
get to that later i'm working on some
cool things for you the listener
when it comes to supplementation and i
am super selective but i am obnoxious
about this the supplements i take so
we'll we'll save that for another one
the next question that came up a lot was
books i
read a lot and a lot a lot
so a couple of things one is i read as
much as i can get my hands on
whether that's science articles whether
that's books whether that
is the occasional i don't know blog post
and i re-read books a lot my wife is a
literacy expert i like to come back to
books with new eyes and experiences and
i learned this from her and the book
will mean and say new things to me
so i like that so i'm gonna run through
a list here of the books that i love
books that have meant a lot to me that i
still go back to
and here we go fight club by chuck
palahniuk
catcher in the rye by salinger born to
run by bruce springsteen that's a recent
book it's his autobiography it's
extraordinary
i don't want to talk about it by terence
real a book that
changed everything in my life by naseem
talab is
anti-fragile he also has a follow-up
called skin in the game which is a
similar book but
anti-fragile was just rocked my world
from the inside out
come as you are by emily nagotsky is the
best book on sex and intimacy i've ever
read
finding meaning by david kessler is a
book on grief
adult children of emotionally immature
parents by dr
lindsey gibson everybody
with parents everybody with parents who
left them
everybody whose parents who has parents
or have had a parent which means
everybody
should read the book adult children of
emotionally immature parents
if you are a parent you should read it
because it's going to tell you about
yourself
okay nadine burke harris
the book the deepest well i did some
work with aces adverse childhood
experiences and the aces scores
it is powerful and extraordinary and has
the opportunity to change the world from
the inside out
very simply any book by gabor mate
m-a-t-e daring greatly any book by brene
brown
is good it's worth your read erving
yalum the gift of therapy
which is an open letter to young
therapist is good for people entering
into mental health space people who help
other people and it's good by p for
people who are going to counseling to
know what a good therapist would look
like
necessary endings by dr henry cloud is a
classic it's an extraordinary read
um if you're a super nerd behaved by
robert sapolsky he's a stanford
scientist and researcher it's a magical
book but it's also dense and so if
you're not a super nerd it may not be
for you but it's
remarkable for those leaders in business
pat lincione any book by him
for just fiction that's fun ready player
one by ernst klein i love that book
as a kid of the 80s and 90s that book
was rad mating in captivity but esther
perel is a is an excellent book on
relationships just talking about how
relationships are shifting underneath us
predictably irrational by dan aureli was
awesome
why we get fat by gary tobbs that's
that's like a mystery novel
into what has happened to our country
the last hundred years and it's
remarkable
the road by cormac mccarthy for you dads
especially dads of sons read that book
you won't sleep well but it's a good
book
huck finn is magic justice by michael
sendell
anything by tim wise rob bell richard
rohr nt wright richard beck
these are guys i know people disagree
with but they stretch us if you are
theologically minded too they stretch
and push and make you uncomfortable make
you think differently
richard beck is a close close friend of
mine anything by anne lamont is good the
body keeps the score by
bessel vander kulk and now here's a
here's a
here's a magic little tidbit
i don't read any sort of anything
scientific or insight or philosophical
at night
i only read young adult fiction
so here's some of my favorite young
adult fiction the harry potter series
obviously
the wing feather saga by andrew peterson
it's remarkable the wildwood trilogy by
colin malloy so good and the wilder good
series by sj dalstrom i talk about texas
a lot
if you got young kids while they're good
series buy them all
and buy them right now they're excellent
also almost as important as books
is i've had some transcendent moments
over the course of my life with
poets and with stand-up comedians so
here's a little insight into me i had my
life changed with a group of poets
from the deaf comedy the deaf poetry jam
series
lisa connell lisa jesse
peterson they spent a weekend with me
and really transformed my life as a
young adult
the collective poems of langston hughes
i i'm a huge poetry fan
and we can go on and on into that and
then comedians as a kid
i used to study comedians my parents had
comedy records and i would lay down and
listen to them i would keep
notebooks little spiral notebooks of
what jokes worked and why they worked
and what was fun and what wasn't fun
so i was obsessed with cosby and pryor
i think dave chappelle is leveled up
over everybody right now
obviously everybody swears a lot they
talk about whatever fill in the blank so
these aren't for everybody these are
just folks who have meant a lot to me
stand-up comedians i love them because
they are the last great bastion
of art it's just them and a microphone
there is no filter between them and an
audience and so they can connect in real
time
and they go there you go to watch a
comedian with one expectation
make me laugh and they have to overcome
that expectation in a really remarkable
unique way
louis black is one of my favorites um i
took my dad to a lewis black concert
when we were
adults and i remember looking over he
was laughing so hard and i thought he's
gonna die right now he's laughing so
hard
and then i thought what better way to go
what better way to die than in a
stand-up comedy
show he didn't die by the way he made it
steve martin records obviously seinfeld
was was good um is good and name
nate bargotsky is that who that is nate
bargoski now he's hilarious dude that
guy is awesome he's one of the new
comedians coming up
um so those are folks that i love
and then i'll get into music i'm all
over the place with music
so i'm gonna rattle it off i'm not
advocating for any of these groups
told kelly we both share a love for old
guns and roses
when guns and roses got back together a
couple of years ago
me and my old buddies got together
and we went to the show and about two
songs in
i was singing along no it was the first
song i remember where the first song was
and i was singing at the top of my lungs
and then i just stopped
and i was like well mr axelrose
i have a daughter and i can't sing this
song this is inappropriate and you're
rude and you shouldn't be saying these
things
and so as a parent it's totally
different as an adult it's totally
different
as a grown up right but here are some of
the groups that have shaped me and
occasionally i'll go back to him
sometimes i go back to him a lot
i'm not going to tell you which um when
it comes to metal i was a huge
obsessive pantera fan deftones of course
the big four and if you don't know who
the big four
are just go past that rage against the
machine dream theater i love those bands
all 80s hair metal i loved it all of it
poison was special to me obviously
all those bands don't even get into them
all of them jeff leopard's the best
def leopard was legit hey i saw when i
saw them in the concert i remember
thinking like these guys are really good
like they could play well they were
awesome
i saw all those bands they were great
warrant and rat and
all of them i love old punk bands like
bad brains and henry rawlins a black
flag
one of my favorite bands of all time is
social distortion i used to love sick of
it all and hate breed all those hardcore
old punk bands
i really love the killers i really love
especially old but i love foo fighters
those two bands are
excellent excellent what i'd call pop
rock bands
i was a huge fan of the punky new wave
bands which were like trippin daisy and
ned's atomic dustbin
and then man the pop punk like blink and
30 foot fall
mxpx and goldfinger all those bands i
loved and then one day my wife when she
was my girlfriend took me to a show
and really everything stopped and
changed for me and a guy walks out on
stage with an acoustic guitar
he's a christian singer named bebo
norman and i watched him
capture an entire theater just all the
air sucked out of that room
and he just started singing and people
were hanging onto every word i'd never
been to a singer-songwriter show like
that
and i wish i had another word but it's
transcendent and
he was controlling an audience the same
way i had seen
phil and selmo of pantera control an
audience just hanging on every word
and so then i went down a rabbit hole
and really became fascinated and in love
with
singer-songwriters like cademan's call
eric peters who's also a great friend
andrew peterson andy osinga great
songwriters
and then ani defranco was an important
influence in my life damien rice
obviously bebo
and then some of the best living
songwriters in the world i think
frank turner the avett brothers brandon
flowers who's the lead singer of
the killers springsteen andy peterson
those i mean just extraordinary
writers they're poets and they're
songwriters they're awesome
and then we get into hip-hop and rap
toby in wing way is
hands down the best rapper out right now
he's from houston he's
incredible i do love old jay z and old
biggie and dre was the beaten hook
master
old warren g and the houston rat little
flip and mike jones and switch to house
those things are near and dear to my
heart they're way
down in my dna for better and for worse
i love old run dmc and m and beastie
boys
the license to ill records up there the
top one of my favorites
old ll cool j and grandmaster flash i
love all old cube all those i love them
and then i really really love old soul
singers like nina simone and aretha
i don't talk about that a lot but i love
them i really love old
guitar players like hendrix and stevie
ray
ani defranco was a stunning guitar
player
and then the newest guy guy clark if
you're not listening to guy clark jr
that dude is
something special and then i love
ambient electronica
and lo-fi beats when i am writing
and sometimes i level country like
johnny cash and willie and garth and
merle and those guys
and my buddy aaron watson there in texas
he's i guess texas country they call him
he's good too
i i like i like all of it so real quick
here's the movies that were
hold up hold up i feel like you left out
a really important 90s
alternative band third i blind yup yup
there we go
third eye blind can write a pop song and
in between it
talk about heroine and murder and all
these things right
and so you find yourself singing along
like
and then you think i probably shouldn't
be singing that out loud and i'm gonna
have to cancel myself for a second but
i was in middle school and i didn't know
what half the things meant and as an
adult i was like oh that's what that
means
there you go so awesome movies that were
impactful to me
goodwill hunting i saw goodwill hunting
and i wouldn't change my major the next
day
from his journalism our business i
changed it to
counseling not because of the good
because of the will hunting character
because of robin williams
oh back to um comics i loved watching
robin williams
stand by me is my number one favorite
movie of all time
meet the parents when my buddy my oldest
best friend in the world was in a car
wreck he's a paraplegic now but
the movie meet the parents was on loop
and repeat and there was something about
the comedy of that and the friendship of
that
that means a lot to me requiem for a
dream darren aronofsky film
is dark dark dark but awesome spaceballs
in major league
karate kid one and two and i don't care
who you are titanic was awesome
and if you're like nah dude the movie's
so lame you're lying you're lying the
movie titanic was awesome
jack i'll never let go so good american
history x was a powerful movie for me
all the early sandler movies will
ferrell movies what's y'all's favorite
movie
oh man that's tough oh no easy godfather
one and two
no question no question and you run
this ship like don corleone which is so
great
kind of well at some point in time you
will be asked
i will do a favor for you you will be
asked to return it
exactly mine's probably danny darko
donnie darko huh yeah
great music this tells you a lot about
james and i the godfather series donnie
darko
exactly james by the way is dressed in
all black right now
there's gray yeah he livened it up today
for the ask me anything and he's wearing
gray and
kelly is got an ak-47 across her lap
right now
just just in case things go down hey you
know you want to be prepared
any time it can go down that's right all
right so those are just the broad
influences the things i do here are some
questions people started digging into
like my personal life so these are fun
i'm gonna go through them
how do you like living in the woods as
opposed to the city i love them both
i kind of love everything that's the
common theme in my life i mostly like
everything i love being in nature i like
growing my own food we got a big garden
chickens and deer and turkey et cetera
there is some great research about
fractals mandelbrot stuff if you want to
have your mind blown um read about
mandelbrot
and fractals how he came up with the
patterns and clouds it's extraordinary
but
trees clouds holes in the ground grass
hills water we're designed for fractals
not for smooth lives of
72 72 72 degrees from our home to our
car to our office to our car back to our
home we're designed for rises in
temperatures
and drops in temperatures and
uncomfortable things and seasonal things
we're not designed our bodies aren't
designed to eat apples every day
we can't process that much sugar and so
i love being out in nature
i love being kept awake because the moon
is so bright because the stars are so
bright it's like someone's shining a
spotlight over my house that's awesome
i also loved living downtown i love
being downtown nashville
i like walking around in the thick of
things i like the pulse of the city i
love being able to just run over to a
stand-up comedy club or to go to
concerts and then be home in 10 minutes
i love all that and i grew up in a
suburb north of houston
i love that too i love the community i
love the neighborhood so
it's it's really just deciding to be
present and love where you're at but
right now i'm really loving being close
to nature
next question why do you block out your
kids pictures on social media
the short answer is i've been behind
closed doors with tech people from all
over the country
and what they are doing with digital
footprints what do they do what they're
doing with
facial recognition technology the
psychometric maps they're building of
our kids
where our kids go where our kids do what
they think their test scores their
facial
recognition stuff all that just makes me
uncomfortable
i hope people can use that for good they
may not
and so at the end of the day i want to
protect my kids digital footprint
they didn't ask for this life and so i
want to let them opt in
and as we get into you know the facial
recognition stuff i don't want there to
be a
path of my child's life that's scripted
out for them that's my fault
and so um the best i can i want them to
be able to tell their own stories how
they want to tell it when they are old
enough to understand what telling their
stories means
and until then um i'm gonna block their
faces out preach
they're beautiful yeah james with me on
the tech stuff
my kids are beautiful hilarious they're
their mom is my wife is beautiful
and so they got good jeans on her side
and i'd love to be able to show their
faces they're hilarious and fun to be
around
but i want to keep them off the internet
as long as i can
and by the way we're weird about that
one of my best friends in the world came
to visit recently he took out a phone
and i said hey dude don't take pictures
of my kids
and he was like are you serious you
idiot and i said yeah i know it's weird
but
i just don't want pictures of my kids
floating around as much as possible and
so
i i protect it as much as i can we ask
our parents not to post pictures
sometimes they do sometimes they don't
but that's where we're at
how long have i been married i got
married in 2002 so it's at 18 years
and we dated five years before that so i
have
with a bunch of breakups it's a whole
thing um but
my wife and i've been together more than
half of our lives and that's kind of
cool
and kind of weird what's up with my
favorite food an awesome hamburger with
sweet potato fries
a giant rib eye that's cooked barely
medium and deer and elk backstrap are my
favorites
i just love those what's my enneagram
myers-briggs blah blah so
ian kron and i met he says i'm a two
i guess he wrote the book on it
literally so i trust him um
i've also been told i'm a four strong
wing five
and i have also think i can be a three
and a partridge in a pear tree
and i'm an infp i'm an introvert
mostly but also sort of an extroverted
has like an ie with a slash in between
it
so here's my thought on these things
they're mostly nonsense
they mostly don't have tons of research
behind them
but they do have one thing that i love i
love
any sort of tool that inspires people to
go look in the mirror and be
introspective
i don't like the tools because people
use them predictively and prescriptively
and they use them to label other people
and
they use them to label themselves so
i've been in rooms where they're like
we don't need to hire them because
they're an enfj
or yeah that person's a ford so they're
really going to struggle in this role
using those tools like that is is evil
it's wrong it's very similar to
well you know people who look like that
aren't going to be a good quarterbacks
or she grew up in this kind of
neighborhood so we probably shouldn't
let her come work at this company i
don't like that
in fact i hate that i don't like the
judgment part of those type of tools
they people will use these tools to
define and limit and judge themselves
and others i don't like that
i do like when people look in a mirror
and say
huh i do have a default setting that
kind of looks like that
i don't want to be like that or maybe i
can lean into that and fill in the blank
so when you use these tools in a
positive way reflective way
awesome knock your lights out with any
and all of them patrick lyncione just
came out with one that
is real short and i love it it's great
um
the enneagram is is making is
is helping bajillions of people strength
finder i was
i went to the gallup organization when
that was rolling out years ago
i i just want to caution people that
those are not the end-all be-all and
that you get to decide
every single day who you're going to be
and how you're going to be at
one of my favorite places to travel home
i'm so lame i'm a homebody i love
fishing in galveston bay
i like fishing but i'm just not huge on
traveling
i like being home and resting um that
makes me so lame
and that's one of the things that i want
to start leaning into that i'm a guy who
travels and goes on adventures
in other places not just adventures
where i'm comfortable and safe
but that's just me who in history do i
want to hang out with
obviously i'd love to sit down and have
a meal or two with jesus just to
pick his brain here and there see if
we're
how bad we've gotten off track also
william glasser he's the guy who
developed choice theory he died
about a decade ago i have some friends
who knew him met him
and they said there was something um so
warm and inviting same with carl rogers
probably
who had not a single judgment bone in
their body
and that when you were in their presence
you just simply you dropped
your shoulders automatically you just
felt loved and not awkward or weird
he just looked at people as though i'm
so glad you're in my presence and
i want to be around people like that and
i want to become that for myself and for
other people so
those are the people i'd want to just
hang out and meet with i guess george
washington would be cool
um any of those famous guy i don't know
abe lincoln probably cool although he
was kind of miserable i don't know if
he'd be fun to hang out with you're
probably kind of boring like hang out
with james a little bit
um how did you and your wife meet
so imagine this i'm in the
like the student center of my little
college
i've got real long hair i hardly ever
shower because i'm a cool punk rock
cool guy and my buddy justin shows up
and he has a sister who's in high school
a senior in high school she'd come up to
visit him
and she shows up she is west texan she
has a braided belt her pants are tied
just below her neckline and
she looks like she came straight off of
a farm and i look like i came straight
out of a back alley somewhere
and he said this is my sister john hey
wife our main sister this is my friend
john you all are going to get married
someday i thought y'all should meet now
and we were both looked at each other
and were like yeah no that's disgusting
and weird
and then we she came to that college
year later then we met and we broke up
we met we broke up we did it we broke up
i think we broke up five times total and
then we've been together ever since
and that's the story i got introduced by
my brother-in-law one fun
story about that is once we started
dating officially the next year
he said hey um i know you're about to
start dating my sister and we're friends
but since you're dating my sister we
can't be friends anymore and i was like
oh okay
and literally he quit talking to me it
was awesome he's like dude you're dating
my sister that's weird i'm gonna be your
friend
and i loved it and then we got married
and then it was back on it was legit man
and i spent a week with him last week
out in the woods and he's just a great
extraordinary guy
just a stud so that's cool um things
that get me the most
anxious what gets me the most anxious
um broadly speaking
climate change and economic issues and
not like oh dude liberal bro
like i've sat in meetings after meetings
after meetings with climate science
scientists and looked at the data and
the tables and there's just some scary
stuff out there
um economic issues
what we have managed to do in the last
50 or 60 years is just unimaginably
unsustainable
the way we have moved the stock market
the fact that we owe 25 trillion dollars
those things aren't sustainable and
if you look back at history they don't
end well
and so it will take an extraordinary
coming together of people
making wise decisions that everybody's
going to be uncomfortable
everyone's gonna have to change
everyone's got to do hard things
for a period of time for a greater good
and just watching how we've handled
kovid
and watching this the last election
season like it's it's been hard on me
because i thought people could come
together over big issues and
this has made me doubt whether that's
possible and so
um i'm back to helping
people in my sphere people who call my
show who i interact with every day
people who come to our events that will
read the books that i put out
that's where i can be a person of
influence and a person of support and
kindness
and that's the best i can do and my hope
is that we have a consciousness change
that we all begin to see each other as
neighbors and not as
people that we hate and people that
we've got to work together on for the
sake of our grandkids but
those are two big things that that make
me anxious
and mainly it's because i can't do
anything about them i can not owe money
i can be a part of um
being honest about the banking industry
i can ride my bike more
right i can get solar panels on my house
i can do those things but at the end of
the day
some of these systemic things are just
way bigger than me and so those make me
anxious i can't do anything about them
i'm anxious about the future my kids are
inheriting and i'm anxious about
um kind of a a movement towards
the pathologization of discomfort
you said something that made me
uncomfortable so you can't talk once we
get rid of free speech that's a that's a
dangerous slippery slope and that free
speech means i can say what i want and
you can too
and they can too so if you go back to
some of the aclu stuff when they were
defending nazi
sympathizers that's evil and ugly and
gross
but the fact that we have free speech
means people can say what they're going
to say even if they're idiots
and so that's just messy but again i'm
also super optimistic this is kind of
optimistic guy by nature so
how much money is in my swear jar right
now
i swear way way way way way too much
a lot is what i'm gonna say a lot what
was the biggest change coming from
tennessee to texas giving up my driver's
license
that's just weird handing it over it was
though i don't know i was losing
citizenship
um mexican food mexican food in
nashville is
bust dude mexican food in texas is legit
and
i'm preaching my protection it's awful
right
it's just not chewie's is here when i
when i first moved here and i wanted
really great mexican this was 20 years
ago too
and somebody's like we've got this great
place it's called on the border
come on that's like hey i know a great
place to get a burger
chili's yeah nope oh i know we could
crush dinner applebee's
nope that's why when we go home i eat
mexican
for like a week yes yes and so hey
listen if you want to make a million
dollars
bring a great authentic not a million a
bajillion dollars
bringing a great authentic mexican food
restaurant to nashville
and nashville's mexican food is good
it's got like unicorn
and octopus in it like it's all artsy
and what well because we're a foodie
town now
yeah it's all fancy and it's 111 for a
like a miniature burrito that was you
know like the goat grew up and
somebody's home
like it's awesome it's delicious but i
want
like a pig roasting in the parking lot
right behind the building i will buy the
stuff that like
they're roasting it in in the parking
lot of the convenience store
yeah that's i want dirty you need to go
to antioch to nolansville road there's
plenty of that happening
i'm in dude not too far from where we
live so come over and we'll go eat okay
i'm in
what's my beef with crossfit none
here's my beef with crossfit i just lied
they are looking for people who have
beefs with them you can't tell one
joke about one i love crossfit it's a
great exercise program
they don't care about form at all so you
can end up with broken shoulders and
elbows and knees whatever
but they are great for community they're
great for group achievement
um i've got a great mentor and friend of
mine dustin ben
dustin is all in he has um changed my
heart and mind about it it's
great he's a teacher they accomplish
great things together
it's a good and every group
every group get a sense of humor chill
out be reflective
um do you ever find yourself being dr
john when your wife just needs her
husband
no and here's why because i used to be
that and it almost cost me my entire
marriage literally not playing
so um no i was so so bad i was mr advice
giving all the time and it's actually
why i preach against it so hard
now because i i demoralized my wife
so bad i hurt the person that i love and
care about the most in the world
and so no when i get home that stuff is
off
off off i actually ask permission are
you asking for my
input here you want me to listen and she
says i just want you to listen
so no i only give advice in my house
when it's asked for
by my wife and um i'm i'm
pretty pretty open about that even with
my friends i've shifted over the last
three or four or five years too
just listening and not just being advice
guy all the time
what are some of my biggest influences
on the advice i give
no question dr andrew young andy young
who is my crisis team supervisor in
lubbock texas he's an author check out
his books
he's just an extraordinary guy he's a
great human being
and he is the master at going into
uncomfortable hard broken messy bloody
ugly situations and bringing the
temperature down
helping everybody in the room from the
cops to the swat team
to the actual victims to the assailants
everybody
and uh he's the master doctor john will
thompson
showed me how to fire somebody with
dignity and grace how to have hard
conversations how to be direct how to
lean in how to talk
how to be open michael gibson who was my
first
boss he was my first coach that
hired me back in 2000 he taught me how
to love
young people how to listen how to be
what showing up
and being there meant my professors in
grad school dr hendricks dr marbley
um dr latora peggy price those folks um
were incredible
and then my dad my mom they're just
extraordinary watching them over the
years my wife
is a gifted communicator and she is good
at hospitality and creating a presence
for people to feel safe to talk
and then my sister my brother those
folks are good
and then the folks i've read and watched
interacted with over the years yalum
glasser
thousands of people i've sat with um
gabor mate
terence real henry cloud those folks who
just bring their presence with them
writers et cetera so have i had my own
mental health challenges
yes if how did i overcome them get my
new book
how's that that was a pretty dope pitch
um
is a long story i'm still working
through it but um it's a long story
there
that'll be a whole other podcast someday
what's my professional background that's
a whole other podcast um we'll do that
one later
um as with all your knowledge and
experience what has stopped you in your
tracks
good and bad an alligator
um that actually happened once my buddy
and i used to collect reptiles we'd sell
them to a store
in south in the swamps in houston we
stumbled into some alligators once and
that froze us up
not what you're talking about um
the two things that have stopped me in
my tracks one was
when i realized oh my gosh my marriage
is almost over and that was a couple of
times over the last 20 years
those are frozen moments when you have a
i'm going to lean this way or i'm going
to stop and go back this
way those are important moments that
stop
everything i'm leaving work we're
shutting this thing down until we get
this figured out
and then i'll tell the story um
man i was teaching a grad school class
one night
and no you know what i'm not going to
tell that story i'm going to leave that
for another time
i'll tell you this being involved in the
suicide
response of young people um anytime i
get that call from a parent or i have to
give that call to a parent
and say hey your son or daughter is no
longer with us anytime i had to
knock on a stranger's door and be there
with a police officer
and say your child was involved in a car
wreck your husband had a heart attack at
work
anytime i was in those kind of
situations they always stopped me in my
tracks no matter how many times i've
done them
over and over and over again they always
make me stop life is so short
it is so precious and the stuff we worry
about is so senseless and useless
um and those always stop me in my tracks
every time
um what car do i drive a 2006 tundra
with a missing headlight and a 2010
prius
that's not very remarkable how do i deal
with having different
opinions from dave i've got a youtube
thing where i talked about that
and here's the deal at the end of the
day he signs my paychecks his name's on
the building so i kind of
i don't know he's my boss um
ultimate comfort food gummy candies
marshmallows
burgers mom spaghetti hashtag m
m my mom made this old spaghetti that
was dope i don't eat it anymore
but man it was legit gummy candies and
marshmallows i can eat them out of the
bag
who are my mentors dr john will thompson
randy harris dr steven bonner randall
demint
brett hendricks aretha marley susan
blasengame darby dickerson
played an important role in my life dr
ken jones my mom and dad
um dave obviously chris hogan's
been a good influence on me um how do i
manage staying humble and being
successful as i am number one
i'm not that successful number two the
smartest guy i've ever met in my life
is a uruguayan immigrant
named gustavo gustavo mendez menendez
and he's the smartest man i've ever met
he was an engineer he married an
american
um an american missionary they moved
here
and because we're so awesome we wouldn't
recognize his his engineering degree
from home
from uruguay and so he started sweeping
floors in a cotton gin
in west texas and he had 200 bucks in
his pocket and an old beat up 4
truck and he started a business called
gus's lube service
where he would show up to your house or
your business and change your oil in
your driveway
smart right now he runs a massively
successful
mobile lube service business where he
comes and fixes your car
and he cares deeply about people
and he reads and he watches and he
listens and he hugs and he can fix
anything why do i tell you that because
often we talk about success as i've got
these degrees i
am on a podcast i make this much money
and it's hard to think highly of
yourself when the smartest guy you know
is a mobile mechanic who's very
successful and he literally changes
lives from the inside out he's so
generous and so kind
and so i think i'm successful
in my family because my wife and i have
weathered some storms my kids are good
i'm humble because i know how this whole
thing ends when you sit with people who
die when you sit with weeping moms and
dads
you realize this is short man i take
none of this with me it's all temporary
i did work for years with folks with
disabilities
and one of my favorite quotes about
working people with disabilities
is air everybody
is only temporarily able-bodied
at some point it breaks down for all of
us
none of this stuff at work here defines
me my wife does my
faith does my character does
this stuff at work is just awesome it's
just gravy it's a it's a fun
awesome adventure i love helping people
love getting to do
what i love to do it's fun
but i don't take it too seriously um i
don't hold my identity in that
so that's how i stay humble um how do i
deal with shady people
i don't i have a philosophy of my life
called
have a guy have a guy
i know a dude who's a plumber then he is
who i call for everything you know i
will never do is go look and ask
plumbing questions because i know a guy
i have one of my best friends todd is a
banker i only ask todd banking questions
because i have a guy and i don't have to
hold the mental space there i have an
insurance guy that i trust
that's who my guy is and i just go
through my life trying to accumulate
friends and communities who are smarter
than me in other areas
that's why i don't understand when a
doctor gets up and says hey here's the
deal and everyone's like oh
and i always want to say how do you know
man that's a doctor
but whatever so my philosophy on life is
have somebody like i just called a
roofer i don't know any roofers in
nashville
but i know winston cruz rachel cruz's
husband and i trust that guy
and so i said who would you trust to
work on your house and he gave me a
company
and i called them and they're coming out
tomorrow right so have a guy
um so i don't deal with shady people i
make sure people are vetted and people
have integrity then i move on from there
somebody asked me jackson dinky or
charvel dinky
come on people this is a guitar question
gibson les paul or an sg
or 335 if you're fancy or a firebird if
you really want to bring it down
marshall amps but to answer your
question orange amps are pretty dope too
i can't afford them
but to answer your question jackson
dinky all day if you really have to
my opinion about jazz masters sean oh my
gosh
here's the thing if you're a fender
player we're probably not going to be
friends
tom dicioli who's the guy who was my
guitar
compadre for years he played only strats
he's the only guy to get away with it
and you jimmy james childs
you can too you have a jazz master don't
you yes
ugh in fact i think i have only fender
guitars i have one
i have one casino and have fun casino
but i don't have anything without
buckers
deal with it
dealt um my opinion on using weed
and drugs recreationally we're all high
right now
actually it's pretty cool not really um
i'll answer that question later
the big thing is don't do anything
illegal actually i'll answer it right
now
marijuana psychedelics the map studies
they're changing underneath our feet
um i've heard remarkable stories and
catastrophic stories
and all i don't have an opinion yet it's
illegal in the state where i
live i have a very high opinion of
clinical grade cbd hemp extract i've
seen that stuff i've experienced it's
good
but i don't smoke weed i don't use
recreational drugs
um and in some places it's legal
and so people are working with their
doctors to get the help they need i
don't have an opinion on it yet
um what are my thoughts on
myers-briggs already answered that um
how do you give advice to people who
aren't asking for it but you really want
to help
don't don't give advice it took me a
long time to learn this one
live your advice people get their
message by watching you
instead of walking around and
proselytizing about your new diet or
your new whatever which i did
all the time just eat differently
live right live a whole life for you and
people will come ask you questions
um how do i keep
balanced if a question goes against my
beliefs or morals
in short order people don't often call
me with moral
or character or belief questions they're
calling me and saying
help so think of it this way
i may not like synthetic rope i like
rope made out of
i don't know hemp fibers
and i walk by and somebody's drowning
and i see a synthetic rope
on the side of the lake of the river
what we often do is we see somebody
drowning and we say hmm
we shouldn't be using synthetic rope
it's not good
and then they drown because we made a
stand on an
issue and i'm sick of people
being wrapped up in issues whether
they're theological issues or political
issues while people are
drowning and so
what i try to keep in mind when i'm
answering a question is how can i help a
hurting person right now
and if people call me and ask my opinion
on certain things sometimes i'll answer
sometimes i won't i'm not gonna do the
heavy lifting for you
but often beneath my beliefs and my
morals
is a cornerstone of my moral is help
hurting people
a cornerstone of my beliefs is help
hurting people and so
i don't care what issue you're
struggling with
that's that is my morals and my beliefs
and again
that may be a trite easy answer did i
get that right james i don't know
that's what i think about it what's your
answer oh
that went against my morals and beliefs
james i didn't
well played um let's see here
why so many family issues dude
uh on the show i'm assuming
because families are broken at every
shape form and
fashion across the world our families
are our original tribe
our tether our connection and it barely
exists anymore
and so people are spinning out all over
the place because we don't have these
tribal familial connections and so i
think everybody's dealing with it
all over the place and we're gonna
slowly get it back one person at a time
yep um somebody wrote in he's 23 with no
path i'm 24 getting
a doctorate waiting for him to mature
but should i here's what should happen
he should leave you
because you're a jerk that's the simple
you're not better than him because
you're going to grad school
you're not better than him because he's
still figuring out what he's going to do
quit judging him
do you love him he might be a mechanic
he might be somebody who's gonna have a
killer lawn business
right um don't judge him and he
shouldn't leave you whatever but
don't think of it like that um
think of it like do i love this guy we
can be very s
different and separate um all right er
last thing here
that's it that's that's enough for today
so that was a that's almost an hour
today right
of ask me anything uh kelly do you have
a question for me
as we wrap
um no i don't think we have enough time
for all the
questions i would have for you it might
be a little frightening so
james i think i'm good um
you don't like jazz masters we're good
these guys are the worst
and the worst and the best and beautiful
and handsome
all right that's it so as we wrap up
today i'm gonna read you
like for real so i speak in hyperbole
this is if you
if you stuck with us this long you're
gonna get one of my top threes of all
time
this is for real one of my favorite
songs
um james don't read the whole thing is
that cool that's a poem here we go
the screen door slams and mary's dress
waves like a vision she dances across
the porch as the radio plays
roy orbison singing for the lonely hey
that's me and i want you
only don't turn me home again i just
can't face myself alone again
don't run back inside darling you know
just what i'm here for
so you're scared and you're thinking
that maybe we ain't that young anymore
show a little faith there's magic in the
night you ain't a beauty but hey you're
all right
oh and that's all right with me you can
hide beneath the covers and study your
pain and make crosses from your lovers
throw roses in the rain
and waste your summer praying in vain
for a savior to rise from these streets
well now i'm no hero that's understood
all the redemption i can offer girls
beneath this dirty hood
with a chance to make it good somehow
hey what else can we do now except
roll down the windows and let the wind
blow back your hair
the knights busted open these two lanes
will take us anywhere
we got one last chance to make it real
to trade in these wings on some wheels
climbing back
heaven's waiting down the track
i'll skip down here too there were
ghosts in the eyes of all the boys you
sent away they haunt this dusty beach
road
and the skeleton frames of burned-out
chevrolets
they scream your name at night in the
street your graduation gowns lies and
rags at their feet and in the lonely
cool before dawn you hear the engines
roaring on
when you get to the porch there gone on
the wind so mary climb in it's a town
full of losers
i'm pulling out of here to win oh
thunder road
bruce springsteen from the born to run
record in 1975
the boss
merry christmas good folks this is the
dr john dalona show